Shown here is the homepage for dimple js.
You can find it at dimplejs.org.
As I mentioned, dimple is a library built atop of d3
that allows us to work at the abstraction level lower chart.
Rather than lower level abstractions like visual end codings,
such as shape, scale and positioning.
The reason I'll be using dimple.js instead of
another charting library is three-fold, as outlined on their site.
Dimple is built atop d3.
Has a very gentle learning curve and designed for analysts.
And the last reason and
what's pretty unique to dimple is that it exposes the native d3 objects.
So if you do want to get more complicated and
ween yourself off of using all of dimple's convenience methods.
You can access the underlying d3 objects themselves.
As I mentioned dimple.js exists as a tool to
make business analysts more productive with charts.
But to allow the flexibility to extend the visualizations for power users.
Even though we saw d3 in lesson one, we only manipulated HTML objects and
a little SVG, and did not get into any data driven operations.
We will be using d3 itself to create interactive visualizations and
animations in lesson four.
But for now, since we're only creating charts and
since many awesome libraries exist.
They abstract a lot of the complexities of building charts yourself with d3,
we'll be using the libraries instead.
This pattern that d3 defines to bind data to some elements on the page
is often one of the most confusing topics for newcomers to d3 to understand.
Most often due to the .enter and .exit commands you can call on your data.
These are only really relevant if you're adding and removing elements on a given
webpage in an animation, transition, or interaction.
They are necessary, however, for any simple visualization you do,
even if you don't have any interaction or animation in it.
Rather than explain this pattern now and
having you wonder why there's this dot enter, or how it could be used.
I'll save the explanation for lesson four when
we will fully understand what's going on behind the scenes here.
And how we can leverage it to create some pretty awesome interactive
animations and visualizations.